today's guest is professor michael levin
a developmental biologist and synthetic
biologist at tufts university in my
opinion his work is worthy of a nobel
prize being the equivalent of
discovering dna as the basis of genetic
memory though instead of a biochemical
code he found a bioelectric one and
instead of genetic memory at the low
level it's large-scale anatomical
structures at the high level click on
the time stamp in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro michael
evans work has direct implications for
cancer research the regeneration of
limbs the possible regeneration of
tissue in general and thus may aid with
alzheimer's research the creation of
engineered life that can scour areas for
toxins and remove them
the creation of an entirely new drug
market based on non-neural bioelectric
manipulation and even recovering traits
that have been in species that have went
extinct millions of years ago that live
in us via mechanisms we're only now
beginning to understand because of
michael and his teams and his
collaborators teams work truly truly
groundbreaking for those new to this
channel my name is kurt jaimungle i'm a
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of what are called theories
of everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as delineating
the possible connection consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of nature
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us
if you enjoy witnessing and or engaging
in real-time conversation with others on
the topics of psychology neurobiology
physics consciousness free will god and
so on then do visit the discord and the
subreddit the links for those are in the
description there's also a link to the
patreon in the description that is
patreon.com
kurt jaimungle as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason i'm able to
do this full time it would be near
impossible for me to have conversations
like this with any fidelity with any
depth
on topics like consciousness loop
quantum gravity geometric unity that's
coming up string theory non-neural
bioelectric manipulation and so on if
not for the patrons and the sponsors
thank you and again that link is
patreon.com kurchimongo speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is algo algo is an end-to-end supply
chain optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception
now omdat has a podcast on ai and
consciousness and if you'd like to
support this channel that is the toe
channel then please visit the
description and support his channel as
doing so supports this indirectly the
second sponsor is brilliant brilliance
illuminates the soul of mathematics
science and engineering through these
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world it
elevates math and science from something
to be feared to a delightful experience
of guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model is contingent on u1 cross
su-2 cross su-3 those are technically
called lead groups and those are local
symmetries visit brilliant.org toe that
is t-o-e and i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
comprehend subjects you had previously
had a difficult time grocking don't stop
before four lessons thank you and enjoy
this non-blessing and wondrously
eye-opening conversation with professor
michael levin
i think what you're doing is nobel
prize-winning work well thank you so
much that's very kind thank you i'm
extremely
very much looking forward to this thank
you when i was researching you about
every 10 minutes or so you would say
this
some offhand comment that would
floor me because of its consequences and
then you'd move on and then you'd say
what trumps what came before and this
happened over and over
so why don't you start with
what non-neural bioelectric states are
their relationship to anatomical results
and then later we can compare and
contrast to standard developmental
biology for decades which is it's the
genome that instructs constructs perhaps
what's epigenetic so we'll start with
what are bioelectric non-neural
bioelectric states and their
relationship to anatomical results
sure uh okay well
so so non-neural bioelectrical states
are simply the fact that all cells in
your body not just neurons have the same
machinery that's normally associated
with neural cells so ion channels
electrical synapses neurotransmitter
pathways all of these things are way
older than nervous systems and all every
cell in your body is creating an
electrical potential across its membrane
most cells in your body are
communicating those states to their
neighbors via these electrical synapses
and
on the one hand people are often
surprised to hear this on the other hand
if you ask yourself where did neurons
and brains come from they didn't just
spring up out of nowhere evolution
basically
uh speed optimized processes that were
already here around the time of
bacterial biofilms they're ancient these
things are ancient
and so
uh
if you if you just uh sort of track back
the phylogeny of of nervous systems and
neural cells you find out that all cells
have these and in fact we've had
discussions very lengthy discussions on
some of these basal cognition meetings
in terms of what is a neuron you know
people people will say well here are
neurons and i'll and i'll say by the way
what's a neuron and so they'll write on
the board four or five criteria for what
they think is a neuron and then they say
well every cell does this and so uh
there are a couple of there are a couple
of differences but but but most things
are fairly universal and so then the
question becomes we'll find what are
they used what is this used for so in
the brain what you have is a system
where an electrical network is
processing information to
direct muscles that move your body
through three-dimensional space that's
behavior nervous system control of
behavior
in
prior to that what these systems were
used for were to generate signals that
control cell behavior to move your body
configuration through anatomical space
that is the space of possible anatomical
configurations so i think um and i'm
working on some more stuff on this now
in terms of really broadening this this
idea but but i think what evolution did
was pivot some of the same tricks
across different spaces so electrical
uh electrical networks were used to
control to traverse
first in evolution probably first
metabolic spaces and then physiological
spaces and then transcriptional spaces
and amorphous spaces and eventually
three-dimensional space when mussels
came on the scene and animals could run
around and do things like that
but uh that's that's what electrical
networks used to think about before they
thought about behavior in
three-dimensional space they thought
about navigating other types of space
now how does this compare to the
standard view which is just it's our dna
that programs us the the the the
standard view is correct in the
following sense what the dna specifies
is the structure of the micro hardware
of your cells so the dna gives you the
protein level
uh sequence meaning the the structure of
the proteins that every cell has that's
the hardware so the dna the dna is what
specifies the hardware of the cells now
it turns out that that hardware is
awesome it's it's amazing in the
following way when you put that hardware
together it not only has specific uh
sort of default behaviors but it also
has lo it has computational capacity and
it's reprogrammable that that's that's
so that's actually one of the most
exciting parts about it but uh the the
the the the standard view is that
you should be able to
uh very directly go from what's in the
genome to
the anatomical structures and i i think
what that view is missing is a very
important middle layer that sits between
the hardware and then of the anatomy of
the the hardware of the genome rather
and the final outcome this the santa
these this anatomical homeostasis that
we see in regeneration and development
and so on and that layer is the software
it's the physiological software that
that uh that links those two things
together
can you tell me some of the experiments
that you've done take the audience
through a couple of the experiments so
one you amputate a frog's leg and then
you're able to regenerate it so on and
so on maybe outline three that you find
most flabbergasting
sure sure um okay uh let's see so so so
here's one
if you use a voltage-sensitive
fluorescent dye which basically just
reports you flood your your tissue with
it and it just reports
with with um different types of
fluorescence it reports where the
different voltage values are if you look
at the early embryo as it's putting its
face together for example you will see
something we call the electric face and
this was discovered in work with my
colleague danny adams where
we found this thing called the electric
face which is basically that prior to
all the genes being turned on that are
required to make different face
components and so on and certainly prior
to the anatomy there is a an electrical
pre pattern that you see in that region
that
basically looks like a face you can see
where the eyes are going to be because
that's where the voltage is different
you can see where the mouth is going to
be you can see where the placards on the
side of the head are going to be and so
you see this electrical face and it and
it raised the obvious uh the obvious
question which is that if that pattern
is instructive then you ought to be able
to do two things you ought to be able to
mess it up and thus disrupt that
electrical pattern and thus get defects
in craniofacial patterning and and
certainly you can do that and in fact
there are even human channelopathies
where humans have mutations and ion
channels that give them craniofacial
birth defects and defects of limb and
brain and other things so that
that so that's that's true but the other
thing the more exciting thing you might
be able to do
is to take some of those electrical
patterns and move them somewhere else
and you could say okay if if this is the
type of pattern that says to the cells
build an eye here
could we move that electrical state to
somewhere else not move the cells but
move the electrical pattern
reintroduce that electrical pattern
somewhere else and and get it to build
an ion so this is actually we we did
this this is some of our some of our
earlier work um you know around uh 2007
or so we we discovered this uh basically
you take one ion channel that's able to
induce a particular electrical pattern
in in the in a region of cells and you
inject rna encoding that ion channel in
some other part of the embryo that's
going to be gut let's say okay it's
going to make endoderms to make gut
cells
and sure enough uh and so and so three
things are significant about what
happens the first is that you get an i
then you get an i in the middle of the
gut you get an eye constructed from
cells that were going to be gut
so this is remarkable because if you
look at the um
developmental biology textbooks what you
will see is that they say that cells
outside of the anterior neuroderm are
not competent to become eyes they're not
supposed to be able to make eyes and
that's true if you use the the
biochemical master eye gene pac-6 if you
if you try to re-induce eyes with pac-6
that's true it doesn't form and it you
can't get ectopic eyes anywhere outside
the head but by introducing this
bioelectric pattern you can and so
that's so that's the first thing that
you you can you can
go beyond the known uh competency limits
by using this very upstream sort of
master regulator this this electrical
pattern the second thing that's
interesting about it is that
the information content that we provide
by putting in this channel is extremely
low we don't micro specify the details
of how to make an eye you know i has a
dozen cell types all arranged in a
particular way we don't know how to do
that we couldn't possibly do you know we
couldn't possibly do that in fact
what what we do instead is provide a
very simple signal
that to a programmer basically looks
like a subroutine call right it's a
trigger it's a trigger for a cascade
that the animal already knows how to do
it already knows how to make eyes we're
not saying how to make an eye what we're
saying is
make an eye here
but by triggering that that eye building
module which includes all the gene
expression everything else that's
downstream so that modularity that that
that incredible um engineering trick
that uh that that says that you can call
up once you know how to do something you
can reuse it
in other places the fact that these
bioelectrical states are triggers of
developmental subroutines okay so that's
that's kind of the second cool thing
about it the third cool thing about it
is that if you label the cells that you
are injecting the channel rna into with
some with us with a color so you can so
you can tell which cells actually got
the
the extra channel and then you and then
you look at that eye that you've created
what you will see is that often for
example half the eye
will have the channel you put in the
other half the eye doesn't have it that
means that what the cells that you
affected what they did was they
recruited their normal neighbors
right which by themselves were never
modified by you they were completely
wild-type and
and yet they got recruited by their
neighbors to be part of this thing so
there's two levels of instruction here
there's instruction by us saying to a
region you make an eye and then there's
a secondary instruction by those cells
that say oh and by the way i'm going to
need more cells hey you guys over here
you're going to be part of this lens and
they all come and they even the ones
that we never directly affected and so
this third part is cool because
well the the the second part is cool the
the fact that it's it's modular and a
trigger is cool because that means that
you can
achieve regenerative medicine outcomes
things that are way too complex for us
to micromanage by using triggers if we
can identify
the triggers of the subroutines that we
want make an eye make a layer make a
liver
then we can trigger those things long
before we actually know all the details
about how to micromanage it right so
part of part of reverse engineering and
i very much see this as a reverse
engineering task part of reverse
engineering is finding out all the cool
hooks in the system that are already
there for you not that you have to put
them together from scratch but they're
already there for you what is the
trigger that that's the build and i sub
routine what other subroutines are there
right that's that's that's part of our
job the other the thing that's cool
about that third part is that it's
non-cell autonomous meaning
you can exert effects on cells without
touching them directly because cells
communicate to each other so by
convincing
a bunch of cells over here that they
should make an eye you in effect uh
affect a bunch of other cells and cause
them to be part of that eye without
having to touch them directly and that
comes up
sorry that's what you meant when you
were talking about recruiting earlier
exactly exactly right exactly right yeah
so that's so that's kind of the first
that's the first example um that that i
would i would talk about the second
example i would talk about uh has to do
with has to do with cancer and so
michael is it okay if we hold on that
cancer result because what you said was
so profound and i want to unpack it okay
sure sure yeah we'll hold on tell me if
this is broadly correct let's imagine
i'm a frog where the frog is
developing before an eye or a stomach or
a throat or whatever it is is made you
see some ad abrasion some atomization
some electrical atomization like a hint
of it and then what you could do is you
can say well there's some pattern let's
imagine it's a circle to be simplistic
there's some circular voltage gradient
and that means i so what if i induce
that what if i induce a voltage gradient
over here near the heart i know you said
something but whatever over here
then what will happen
is instead ordinarily we would think
well you need to micro tune that eye
each molecule it's extremely difficult
to make an eye we don't actually know
how to from the bottom up molecularly
make an eye but we see this pattern what
if we put that pattern on the heart or
the stomach oh lo and behold some time
amount later then an eye is born is that
correct yeah that's that that's that's
correct and the only thing i would add
to that first of all is that the reason
i was i was telling you about that
electric face pattern is because it's
kind of the most obvious one in the
sense that the electric face pattern
actually looks like a face you can't
miss it it just it just looks like a
face but not all of them are that simple
some of them are really um
kind of uh um
they're encoded more deeply such that by
by staring at it you can't tell what
it's going to be right so so for example
there are there are other patterns that
we've seen where the only way we know
what they are is is by watching what
they make we you couldn't have guessed
you know so some some of them are very
direct almost a paint by numbers you can
sort of see what's going to happen and
others are really complicated and you
need
computational tools to deconvolve what
you're looking at to figure out what
it's going to be so so not all of them
are as obvious as as the electric face
pattern right yeah one of the questions
i had was why hasn't this been found out
before was there a technological limit
or did they just not look at cells with
the dye that give an indication of
voltage gradients or optogenetic
technologies and so on yeah so so that
so
so that's an interesting question why
why why not before i mean on the one
hand everything has to have a beginning
at some point right so so whenever it
was it would have you know you could
have asked well like why not before
right but hindsight is always obvious
you can always you can always say but
but let's but let's kind of dig into
that um on the one hand there was a
conceptual uh
leap that kept this pretty much under i
mean let's be clear i am not the first
person to talk about the importance of
bioelectric signals people have been
studying endogenous by electricity since
before 1900 so so it certainly has
occurred to people that maybe electrical
signals are important in development
regeneration
all of my work i was i was incredibly
heavily inspired
by by work that was done in this in the
60s 70s and 80s by a bunch of people
that worked really hard on this stuff
the reason that it hadn't gone far
enough was to two reasons number one
the tools weren't there so these dyes
didn't exist all they had was
traditional electrophysiology in
traditional electrophysiology you have
one electrode and you're poking it into
cells and if you want to have a picture
of what's going on you got to poke all
the cells and that's just completely
impractical right these dyes didn't
exist the conceptual thing was that
um around the time that this stuff was
was taking off using using electrodes
and things like that uh biochemistry and
molecular biology took off and the thing
that the reason molecular biology drew
all the attention is because you could
do molecular biology and biochemistry in
dead fixed tissue
so you can you can kill and fix your
cells and you can sequence the dna you
can sequence the rna you can get a
proteome you can get a uh you know all
of these all of these kinds of things
you can do
none of that is possible with
bioelectrics so the minute your cell is
dead all of it goes away
so none of the typical olmics approaches
work so it's it's it's uh it's it's that
much harder and so it really lagged
behind because all the interest went
into the molecular uh you know kind of
molecular biochemistry and uh and it had
to wait for some of these tools to to
come up the third thing the third thing
is is that
i think
while
while people did uh
think about uh the importance of these
bioelectric gradients
nobody to my knowledge uh
before we did it really thought about it
as
the beginnings of the nervous system and
to really put that computational spin on
it the fact that this thing really is
liking neural network doing computations
about development i i think that's new i
i will say um harold burr who was this
guy was working in the 30s 1930s 40s and
50s okay he had one of the first good
volt meters around and he went around
measuring things you know elm trees and
rabbits and tumors and embryos and all
kinds of stuff on the basis of this he
wrote an amazing book um
that basically said most of the things
that we're discovering now the guy had a
crystal ball it's incredible it's
absolutely incredible so he he could
clearly see a lot of this stuff the
thing the the one thing he did not see
because at the time it didn't exist was
the computational aspect and the and the
really the link to um you know to to to
this as as a kind of neuroscience done
in another space in amorphous space that
i think is is new but but uh
people had already had these ideas and
it needed the technology to really make
it to really prove them out and to
really see how it works
i'll be showing people some overlays of
some of the cells with the blue and
green and red voltage colors now voltage
is actually fairly abstract
for most people but what's not abstract
is something like an electron people can
fathom that that has a certain charge so
when someone is looking at these
videos of voltage gradients and they're
colored what is one seeing essentially
i'm asking you to explain what voltage
is simply but in terms of electrons in
terms of something that people can
understand yeah in order to understand
both you have to understand potential
and you also have to understand fields
technically if you want to understand
that correctly yeah um it's not so bad
you don't need to really do much with
fields in this one all because because
all of the things that i'm talking about
are really not fundamentally fields per
se they're just spatial distributions of
voltage gradients and and to understand
a voltage gradient it's it's pretty
simple instead of electrons life i mean
life uses electrons too but mostly the
kinds of stuff that we're talking about
uses a different charged particle they
use
potassium chloride sodium and protons
okay but otherwise same same deal and so
any cell has a cell membrane around it
the outer surface and it has these ion
channels which are these little portals
these little proteins that can open and
close and let specific ions like
potassium or sodium in and out these
potassium so potassium and sodium are
both positively charged so you can
imagine that
if you if you're a cell and you let a
bunch of your positively charged
potassiums out you can have an imbalance
more positives out here less positives
inside so now there's going to be a
voltage gradient basically a battery in
effect i mean that's basically what a
battery is right it's a it's a membrane
with a with a charged disk balance on
across it that's that's all this is so
every cell is a battery it achieves that
by using energy to pump ions in a
particular direction and as a result you
if you were to take a tiny little volt
meter and put it across and people
that's exactly what electrophysiologists
do you put it across that cell membrane
you're going to read a voltage of some
sort you know it's usually somewhere
between i don't know between 20
millivolts and and
70 millivolts something like that right
that's all it is and so now you imagine
doing that for every cell in the tissue
that you're looking at
and you're just going to color every
cell depending on how big that voltage
difference is it's you're going to color
it red if the voltage difference is
quite small that's called being
depolarized meaning there's just not
that much imbalance it's pretty much
it's quite simple you know the ions
inside and outside are pretty similar so
you're going to color those red and then
the ones that are really different where
there's a ton of
positive charges that have been kicked
out so the cell is really pretty
negative that compared to the outside
space that you're going to color those
you're going to color those blue
and that's and that's what and that's
what you're looking at
great okay so now we have some
background as to what
so dna calls for proteins and you can
think of that as low level and then what
you're discovering and you and your
teams and the teams that you collaborate
with are discovering is that there's
these non-neural bioelectric signals and
those are somewhat like large-scale code
some of the implications are
regeneration of limbs barely touched on
that's okay we touched on generation of
actual so generation of eyes not
regeneration of eyes and then you were
about to get into cancer so do you mind
yeah um
so so
so the just just real quick to say the
analogy is that i i think a good analogy
is this the dna is what encodes the
hardware
okay and the electrical dynamics are the
software now a lot of people get upset
at this because they say ah living
things are not like a computer so i am
certainly not claiming that living
things are like the kind of computers
that you and i use on a daily basis
these right this architecture is not
what life is using however the deeper
concept from computer science which is
the idea of reprogrammable hardware and
the idea of software multi-layer
software where you could be programming
at the in the in machine code or you
could be looking for higher level
subroutines and higher level
languages that i think is quite quite
realistic and i think what we're looking
for here is to understand basically to
to to find the
the best
um
the best representation of that software
so that we can manipulate it as uh as as
you know to to advantage basically and
and to understand how evolution
manipulates it and so and so the other
you know you had asked for three
examples so so there are three basic
examples i wanted to give so so the
electric face was one there's a cancer
example and then there's a planarian uh
flatworm regeneration example so the
cancer the cancer example would look
like this um
one of the things about
cancer the the the one way to think
about cancer is to ask the question
why is there ever anything but cancer in
other words
individual cells like amoebas are
extremely competent on their own they
handle single cell level goals quite
well why do they ever get together to
form something like a kidney or a liver
because when you have when when there's
a cancer what you're seeing is a
defection from that process you're
seeing cells that normally should be
working on making a nice organ in store
up keeping a nice organ in an adult
instead of that they go off and they
basically revert to a single cell kind
of existence they they
basically become like an amoeba they
treat the rest of the body as just
environment it's like external
environment so you can think of that
that computational boundary between
between self and world can shrink it can
grow when a bunch of amoebas a bunch of
amoeba-like cells get together and they
build something like an organ or a whole
body that that computational boundary
grows but can also shrink because an
individual cell can say uh uh i'm i'm
not working on this anymore i'm just an
amoeba and i'm gonna do what amoebas do
what do they do they they become two
amoebas and two amoebas become four and
so on they over proliferate and they go
where life is good so they metastasize
to wherever they wherever they want to
go so that's so that's cancer so
so if you think about it that way that
that cancer is this is this like
defection from multicellular cooperation
you can you ask yourself okay so what is
the process that normally keeps them
harnessed towards specific goals and
and so if you ask yourself what what
what what do we know that's a process
that harnesses individual competent
subunits towards larger scale goals
that's very clear that's that's uh the
neural like processing because you have
individual neurons which are cells
but you connect them together into a
network and this amazing computation
starts to take place that can do things
like plan for the future and have
memories and have preferences and goals
on a large scale you know you as an
organism can have goals and memories
that your individual cells don't have so
so we know that electrical networks are
really good at binding
small competent subunits into larger
scale computational agents we do we we
take advantage of that in computer
science we take it evolution takes
advantage of it in in making neurons
so um so we asked the following question
okay could that be the basis of cancer
and now i must say that of course we're
not the first to have this idea okay
again harold burr um had this said this
in the 30s
but so we did we did three things we
said okay first of all when this process
happens can you see using the voltage
dyes can you see the cells defecting
from the electrical network and in fact
that's then in fact you can so what you
can what you can do is you before it
happens so so you can inject a human
oncogene which is going to form a tumor
in a tadpole you inject that into
um
you inject that into a uh
into a tadpole they make a um
they make a they make a you know it
makes a tumor and even before that tumor
becomes uh becomes apparent you can
uh you can see with a voltage die you
can see that those cells become become
highly depolarized they electrically
uncouple from the rest of the tissue and
they go on their way and they just treat
to them the rest of the animal is just
external environment at that point so
they become electrically uncoupled and
that's that's the first thing that that
oncogenes do is electrically isolate the
cell from its neighbors from that
collection of of signals that normally
tell the cell what to do in a larger
context so that's the first thing we did
the second thing we did we said well
if that if that's a potential cause of
cancer
could we
uh could we could we cause cancer
but just by disrupting the electrical
communication directly no no oncogenes
no carcinogens no dna damage no
mutations nothing wrong with the cells
that any molecular biology test could
see
and could we could we cause cancer
because because remember the standard
model in the field for years has been
that cancer is the cause of genetic
damage basically right that it's that
it's a genetic disruption that makes a
rogue cell that has other mutations and
so on so we said fine no we're going to
take completely normal cells nothing
wrong with them and we're going to
simply prevent them from talking to
other cells electrically okay we're just
going to manipulate that and so we did
that and sure enough we made metastatic
metastatic melanoma in tadpoles so so
that tells you that you there doesn't
have to be anything wrong with the
hardware in order to have cancer it can
be a purely physiological phenomenon it
can be caused at the software level
which a lot of people who study
stress-induced cancers and things like
this they kind of already knew but but
but really the paradigm has been that
there has to be a genetic defect at the
at the root of this somewhere okay and
then the third thing we found which is
of course the most exciting thing
which is you can go in the opposite
direction you can you can inject a
really powerful human occaging like a
p53 mutation oncogene for those who are
listening it's just a gene that causes
cancer yeah an oncogene is a is a is a
mutation in a in the normal gene that
causes that that are that is that is
thought to cause uh cancer
transformation to cancer yeah okay so
you can inject that and then if you do
that into into a tadpole
if you at the same time inject an ion
channel that
forces the cell to remain in an
electrical state where it's connected to
its neighbors and it doesn't depolarize
then even though that oncogene is
blazingly strongly expressed there's no
there you you won't you won't have a you
won't have a tumor because you're
overriding that there's a hardware
problem but it doesn't matter because
you're overriding it and saying yeah i
know you want to depolarize but you
can't you have to stay connected to
these neighbors and you're just going to
be part of this and and and we can
override that way a variety of different
different types of oncogenes
okay so i was just having an analogy in
my head it's almost like imagine you
have these kids and they're misbehaved
so you can say well it's the kids who
are the problem and they cause havoc in
the house but if you have an adult who's
stern enough they can override the
misbehaved kids if you leave the kids
without the adult and the hustle bean
shambles in this analogy the adult is
like the electrical communication so you
can force that electrical communication
that standard adaptive electrical
communication
yeah yeah you can you can think of it
that way i mean the the the thing where
i think it it it breaks down a little
bit is that is that you we're not
introducing an extra element that keeps
everybody else in line right we're we're
in effect it's like um
you know it's like it's like it's like
you have a bunch of kids that know what
to do and you've got one that's wearing
uh you know dark glasses and you can't
see and he's causing all kinds of
trouble because you can't see what he's
doing well you can you can sort of you
could put a camera on him or take the
glasses off or something so that he just
goes right back into the into the
interactions with with the you know in
the in the with the rest of the uh
you know the rest of the group it's
about it's about communication it's
about
uh binding the individual competent
subunits towards a larger goal your goal
is not simply to grow as much as you can
the way an amoeba is your goal is to
build a hand or a liver or an eye or
something else it's really about the
scale up of goals and electrical
networks are great for this
does your work have any implications for
what it means to have an identity so
right now you were talking about cancer
as if it's dissociating from the larger
cells yeah and then there are gap
junctions which you've referenced in
your other work and they effectively
make an equivalence class between
signals that i generate as a cell or my
environment or signals from connected
cells i'm unable to tell the difference
between them yep
because i'm unable to tell the
difference between myself and my
neighbor it's as if i'm identified with
them so it has plenty of bearing at
least i see it has plenty of bearings
for what it means for the eye or the ego
in a non-pejorative manner
so what are the implications of your
work for the concept of identity
yeah yeah no you you put your finger
exactly on it so so so two two years ago
i wrote this paper called on the
boundary of the self and it's exactly
this idea it's the way to to uh to
define what is a self at different
scales and uh how does the boundary the
size of that self change okay or over
time and that's exactly the kind of
thing that you that you're talking about
it's having having communication
channels that partially wipe the
metadata on information so that i no
longer know whether it came from you or
or whether it came from me right gives
us a partial mind melt because now it's
really hard to keep an identity if i
can't tell which are my memories and
which are your memories it's really hard
for us to keep uh to keep distinct
identities we become partially unified
and that's that's exactly the sort of
process that evolution exploits to build
larger cells out of um small competent
ones
another astounding experiment of yours
i'm not sure if i should be calling it
an experiment was where you took skin
cells of a frog and then it has
locomotion can you outline what the heck
did you do there and why is that
important
yeah yeah no it's definitely an
experiment um
so so you're talking about our zenobots
uh i think and
the question was that the question that
we're interested in addressing is is
basically this um
where do anatomical goals come from and
in order to illustrate why that's even a
good question i want to talk about
plenaria for just a moment and then and
then you'll see why this this is
important for the xenobots
um
we are we are used to the fact that
uh each species has a specific shape
that is associated with it and that frog
eggs make frogs and and zebra fish eggs
make zebrafish and so on so we're kind
of we're kind of used to that but
the actual question of how do cellular
collectives decide what they're going to
build and when do they stop building
that's very much an open question
and so so one way you can see how how
far we are away from a good
understanding of this is in in a very
simple um very simple experiment
uh
there are there are around so so
planaria are these flat worms that
regenerate when you cut them into pieces
every piece builds whatever's missing
and they regenerate okay that's that's
plenary you can cut them into pieces and
they every piece regenerates to a normal
plenary so there are species of planaria
that have round heads and those type
those cells are really good at building
a round head and then stopping so they
stop when a round head is complete okay
then you got another species of plenaria
that has a very pointy head a truck kind
of a triangular head and those cells are
very good at point at making a
triangular head when you cut it off it
makes a triangular head and then it
stops so i have a simple question if i
take a bunch of the cells from the
round-headed guy and i stick them into
the body of the triangular guy and i let
them sort of get you know get
comfortable and sit around for a little
while then i cut the head off what head
shape are we going to have are we going
to have is one of the head shapes
dominant to the other are we going to
have an intermediate shape or are we
going to have a planarian that never
stops regenerating because neither set
of cells is ever happy about the shape
they're never that stop condition is
never said okay so now so now look the
the important thing is not the answer
the the important thing is
despite all of the
uh papers in nature and science about
the molecular pathways of control of
stem cells and planaria and all these
kinds of high resolution transcriptomics
and all this stuff there is not a single
model in the field that makes a
prediction on this experiment
why because every piece of data out
there now addresses the hardware that
enables individual cells to do cell
things fine
but we have no understanding of what
happens when the cells join together
into a larger scale self that makes
large scale decisions about head shape
head number things like that in
morphospace that navigates morph space
by making these large scale decisions we
have absolutely no idea how those
algorithms work and the fact that we
know how the stem cells work and have
lots of molecular biology about that
really hasn't affected this other
question much at all we we just have no
no models for this because it's too
computationally complex or some other in
principle reason i don't think it's well
no i don't think it's because it's too
complex although it is too complex to
calculate out directly i think it's
because conceptually we haven't found
the right
uh we haven't found the right way to
think about how cellular collectives
make decisions this is this is a
collective intelligence problem this is
not a molecular biology problem we've
been thinking about this as a molecular
biology problem that's not what this is
this is this is trying to read the mind
of a collective intelligence now people
think of collective intelligences as
exotic things like anthills and and you
know bb colonies and things like this
these are collective intelligences
um i want to remind everybody that we
are all collective intelligences we are
all bags of cells
no there is no cognitive agent that is
like this
single diamond that's that's not made of
parts that's sort of unchanging we're
all made of parts any cognitive agent is
made of parts and so your goal is to ask
how do those parts bind together to make
decisions as a collective individual
cells don't know what a head is they
don't know what round round means they
don't know what triangular means right
but the collective sure does and so the
collective is able to navigate morph of
space in this way that we don't
understand the algorithm so if we don't
even we don't even know how to um how to
think about this okay so
um so so so this this is very isomorphic
to problems in neuroscience to problems
in in artificial intelligence it's uh
trying to understand the scaling of of
minds and in in trying to do that we we
pose the following problem
okay standard
tadpoles make you know standard frog
eggs make it make frog embryos and
everybody's kind of used to that even
even though you know you can remind i
always remind my students did you
realize that that if i gave you the frog
genome you couldn't tell me what a frog
looked like right
you could compare it to other genomes
yeah you didn't know what but that was
that's cheating you know
so so so okay so we asked we asked a
simple question
where does the goal of making a frog or
tadpole really come from and how
hardwired is that so what we did was we
took some skin
that we scraped off of an early frog
embryo we set it aside in a different
environment and we said okay now you're
free to sort of reboot your
multicellularity you're here we've we've
we've relieved all of the constraints of
the rest of the embryo you're no longer
getting constructive signals from from
from endoderm and from mesoderm from all
these other things you're no longer
subject to all these other signals
what are you going to do what
what's what's your new what you know
what what do you want to do and there's
a couple of
different options that could have
happened the cells could have
died they could have wandered off and
and sort of when each cell go its own
way they could have made a monolayer of
cells in a dish the way you get in cell
culture all kinds of things they could
have done they didn't do any of that
what they did instead was to combine
together and to form a little ball
that grew cilia these little motile
hairs on the outer surface
now
cilia are normally sitting on the
outside of embryos and they're there to
kind of redistribute the mucus around
and to you know make the pathogens sort
of keep moving and not stick to the skin
they're used to they're used to um
keep the surface of the of the tadpole
clean
uh but instead these cells basically
repurposed that genetically encoded
hardware the cilia themselves are
genetically encoded all the proteins
necessary to make a psyllium are in the
genome and they so so they have that
already but what they did was they
assembled themselves into a new um
into a new kind of uh a new kind of
architecture this this this spherical
thing which and and then and then they
use the cilia to propel themselves so
they started running around they started
moving around and so we have these
amazing videos of them moving around
singly moving around in groups
interacting we're going through a maze
going back and forth in various
configurations they have all kinds of
behaviors they have all kinds they can
regenerate if you if you cut them
almost entirely in half they will like
join back and and and make a
you know make a uh uh
make a make a zenobot again
and
the the the and and so and so the
coolest thing about them is and by the
way we don't know their cognitive
capacities yet okay we don't we we're
only beginning now to start to see can
they learn can they do they have
preferences all these kinds of things we
don't know yet but the coolest thing
about them is that to my knowledge
they're the only
creature on the planet that doesn't
really have
an evolutionary backstory the individual
cells do okay the cells have a long
evolutionary history on earth
but they were selected for that genome
was selected for the ability of these
cells to sit quietly on the outside of
the frog and keep out the pathogens they
were not selected specifically to be
able to get together and run around in a
separate in a separate configuration
away from the embryo where did that all
come from and in fact one of the one of
the things about it is people people
often say well you know when are you
going to buy when you're going to
engineer these things you know knock in
various synthetic biology circuits right
make them do things and we absolutely
will do that but my goal before we do
any of that my goal was to show people
what what can happen while the diversity
that can happen from the exact same
genome with no manipulations whatsoever
because if you because the thing about
these cinnabots is they just have a
normal frog genome they have no other
they have no transgenes no genomic
editing there's nothing different about
them there what we're seeing is the
plasticity of
of this collective intelligence that is
able to make a new functional
proto-organism in a novel way out of the
exact same parts
so there's no genomic editing there did
you manipulate its morphogenetic code
the electrical signals at all not yet no
we're going to we're certainly going to
that's all to come no at this point we
haven't done that this is this is this
is purely native plasticity this is what
these cells already know how to do we we
we scrape them we scrape them off of the
frog and we put them in little holes the
little little sort of depressions
and
i should back up there are two types of
cinnabots okay the one i'm describing
now we literally did almost nothing you
scrape them off the embryo you set them
aside and you say fine now liberated
from all the signals that would have
turned you into uh various uh various
things what do you want to do and this
is what they do on their own
there's another type of zen about which
is actually the one we started with
where we sculpted them a little bit we
um
and this is by the way this is all work
done in in collaboration with uh with
bongard lab at university of vermont and
sam kriegman did did all the
computational model modeling for this
and then um
doug blackiston did the uh did all the
all the microsurgery and everything we
we sculpted them a bit to give them legs
so you basically just it's subtractive
like subtractive sculpting you just cut
away some stuff so that you're you're
left with kind of an ottoman that has
like four or four legs you know and uh
and and we and and we put in a little
bit of a little bit of of muscle and
then it learned to walk so so the muscle
would contract and the thing would
basically walk along that's that's the
first set of xenobots we made the second
one has no muscle it has no nerve it
only it's only skin and those can get
around perfectly well on their own using
these cilia and their our interventions
are extremely minimal
it's important that it was taken off of
embryos or it doesn't matter if you took
it off of a frog much later in
development
um
we haven't we haven't taken it off a
frog later in development but we we have
we have other evidence that i can't
really talk about yet that uh suggests
that it doesn't matter that it's a frog
and it doesn't matter that it's an
embryo we have we have we we have data
on adult cells now
what occurs to me is
i'm wondering
if this has implications for what it
means to be
alive in the colloquial sense so forget
about in the biological sense so we
think of our skin as dead and our bones
are dead and perhaps dead isn't the
right term but let's say animated
animated with life with vim with brielle
yet you showed that somehow you can
still trigger vim and brio
not via this electrical manipulation i
thought it was that but does this have
any bearing as to what we consider to be
alive or it's a dif or it's a are
unrelated
um i'll tell you that uh one of the
things that this kind of work does is
really illustrate the
insufficiency of our vocabulary so
people often argue for example i mean
alive is a funny thing i don't i don't
actually know what alive really i don't
have a good definition the these cells
and these organisms are for sure alive
in the traditional sense i mean the the
cells are alive there's no there's no
getting around that but but but people
will often argue for example are they
robots are they organisms are they uh
you know these are they machines these
kinds of things and and and we we josh
bongard and i wrote a paper addressing
this question basically pointing out
that
though that terminology is almost
useless now it was it was great 50 years
ago when you could
you when when it was really easy to tell
apart machines that were that were that
were boring predictable they were they
were
designed right and living things which
were surprising and interesting and warm
and wet and um and evolved those things
are now so intermixed
that with modern with modern techniques
of digital evolution and bioengineering
and synthetic morphology that
distinction does not exist anymore and
so it used to be that you can sort of
like you could knock on something and if
you hear a hollow metallic sound and you
say ah yeah that that came off a factory
that's a machine and i'm you know
morally um uh okay with taking it apart
and doing whatever i want with it and if
you were to do this and and it was sort
of so soft and squishy then you would
say that's evolved and it's living and i
better i better be nice to it that right
though that easy distinction is just
that doesn't exist anymore so we need we
need a better vocabulary i mean they're
they're alive for sure but if you want
to ask questions about whether they are
machines or robots or living organisms
or that that all that stretches the
vocabulary which is no longer up to the
task
is there a relationship between
perception and this morphogenetic code
and i know i keep using that word
morphogenetic code and yeah forgive me
if i'm abusing the terminology but is
there a relationship between perception
and morphogenetic code i'll give you my
reasoning behind it right now what i see
is i recognize a monitor i see a
microphone i see you you have eyebrows i
see large scale structures then the
question is well is there anything
special about your eyebrows
well
other than you're an attractive man
let's say
physically speaking physics would say
there's nothing special about this
microphone or 10 percent of the
microphone or 10 of the microphone plus
the air slightly around it it's more a
pragmatic matter
that it's a practical that it matters
that i can use this
however when you're talking about this
non-neural bioelectric code it's as if
these large-scale structures that we
recognize as salient and significant
such as a low resolution facet like a
child's drawings of eyebrows nose head
placement and so on that those are there
in the code so somehow what we perceive
is also what is encoded
and i'm curious well is that is there a
confounding factor that influences both
does the morphogenetic code influence
our perceptions
perhaps i can give a better analogy if i
a computer science analogy where we have
machine code and then you have like
what builds a top that builds the top
library is jquery and on html5 and so on
so we have a function bounce which takes
an image and bounces it or texts and
bounces it or one that plays mpeg so the
question is well what makes bounce
or mpeg playing more fundamental well to
me i would say nothing it's us it's what
we use however it's strange that
objectively there's this code for it
yeah yeah um well there's a there's a
lot there and what you just said uh
certainly um perception is a part of
this whole process because in order to
have this kind of um
anatomical homeostasis where
you you uh you you you you damage in you
know an organism like a salamander which
can regenerate most of its organs or a
planarian which can regenerate all of
its organs you you damage it and then it
grows with the right thing and then it
stops when it's done that loop that
homeostatic loop has to have a
perception component because it has to
be able to recognize when it's done so
it has to be able to perceive am i a
correct planarian or not and if i'm not
i'm going to keep remodeling until i am
and at that point so it's an error
minimization scheme and in order to
achieve that error minimization you have
to be able to perceive around you in
anatomical space and to say am i in the
right region of space here is my head
and the right size is do do i have the
right number of eyes um all of that
you need to perceive that and people um
people like grossberg uh and uh at bu
had written years ago about the
relationship between retinal information
processing and development and i
actually think he was he was really on
to something in the sense that i think
most epithelia are basically like a big
retina and that what they're doing is
they're they're they're constantly
surveilling the rest of the animal
or the rest of the body
and making decisions about large-scale
features so not just individual pixels
but things like in the in the retina
you'd be talking about edge detection
motion
things like that and that's what they're
doing they're looking at large scale
features that individual cells cannot
detect so
one way to look at this is that we have
a precedent for this from neuroscience
and from visual from the science of
visual processing the probably the more
accurate way to look at it is yeah that
guess where the retina learned its
tricks right and guess where where
brains learn their visual processing
tricks by far more ancient mechanisms of
cellular groups navigating morphospace
that that's that's what it used to be
before it became the before it became
vision basically
do you believe that the problem of
senescence to the degree can be called a
problem is largely a disruption of
this electrical blueprint rather than
oxidative stress and damage to dna and
so on that or telomeric length that
people think
um i don't have any evidence yet that
there's a bioelectric component to this
i mean i suspect there is but but we
don't have any evidence on it we haven't
really worked on aging per se
i will say that i don't think it's
anything as fundamental as
uh this kind of like thermodynamic decay
or anything like that because the
planaria are immortal they don't have a
a life span limit they live forever and
so they are telling us that it's
possible to be a complex regenerative
organism with uh learning capacity and
so on and not age so so so it's clearly
possible so so the rest is details right
the rest is i i don't think it's
anything as fundamental as
the the the theories that say well look
when you copy things you inevitably make
mistakes so eventually stuff whereas it
wears out if that were true
you wouldn't have plenary so so i don't
think i don't think it's anything like
that i think it's something much more
contingent much more specific uh and and
thus i i'm optimistic that we can
overcome it so there's some work you're
outlining in a previous talk with uh as
i think it was a couple years ago at the
time it was an undergraduate her name
was maya though i don't recall her last
name and she changed between three types
of planaria head
like
i think it was felina mediterranean doro
i don't recall how to pronounce it but
there were about tens of millions of
years apart evolutionarily and that to
me
implies that there
perhaps our structures that are
unfathomably submerged in us from our
past
and then i'm
curious if there's a relationship
between that
between these
let's say these electric blueprints even
though so whatever these electric
blueprints and union archetypes to go
off on a huge speculative jump is the
relationship between them
boy uh that's that's
that's a good that's a great question um
i think that uh
if if one were to
if
let's run it backwards let's say let's
say that
we underst we we have a conception of
jungian archetypes for
neuroscience and psychology
and now somebody could say yeah but
you're saying that all of all of you
know you know neuro neuro psychology
comes from earlier
somatic bioelectrics what would the
jungian what would that look like then
in that right in in that case what would
the jungian archetypes look like in this
other pre-neural
type of of bioelectrics because we do
this all the time we we ask things like
what does memory look like before it was
brain memory what does
bistable visual illusions look like
before they were before there were
brains all of these things that we see
in neuroscience you can ask what the
what the older somatic equivalent look
like so you can do the same thing here
it's an interesting question i've never
thought about it that way but you can
you can ask that question if you ask
that question you get to exactly the
kind of thing you're talking about and
what i would say is well probably in
morphospace there are these stable
attractors corresponding to different
types of shapes of heads different
numbers of eyes different planaria body
plans different all different kinds of
things and what you can do is you can
dial in those different
uh stable attractors by by in in the
state space of the electric circuit by
by shifting that electric circuit state
so uh yeah i think i think that's a fair
i think that's a that's that's a totally
fair way to think about it
your work is so
it's like to me it's like the discovery
of dna
and maybe you're too modest to accept
that as a compliment but i see it as
as that seminal and i wanna well
i'm gonna put this out there i'm gonna
say in the beginning i think this guy's
gonna win a nobel prize
he has not said that like this is not
him saying that i'm saying that well
thank you so much yeah that's that's
that's very kind um there are lots of
people i mean i i think it's important
to say that uh
yeah it's not none of my friend right
now well it's on on two levels so so so
first of all none of this uh came out of
thin air i didn't think of any of this
stuff just you know from nothing i i i i
built this these ideas uh on on on many
other ideas of of really uh kind of uh
really pioneering folks that work for
years and many of them um didn't really
get uh you know didn't get a lot of uh
acceptance from the community so that's
that's important to say is that is that
there's a lot of that out there and uh
and of course the people in our lab
right the the postdocs and and and for
phd students and techs who do the work i
mean it's certainly not not just me
doing all this work there are a lot of
people in this field and a lot of people
in my group so um lots of people um
contribute to push this all forward
we'll get to the audience questions
okay so this one comes from rupert
sheldrake
how does he think
how does he think his conception of
morphogenetic fields relates to mine
referring to rupert
yeah uh interesting question um
so
basically our morphogenetic fields that
we work on
uh are completely physical in other
words they take place entirely within
the body of the organism they're
generated by the cells we can measure
them using
current technology
i don't know if that's true of the kinds
of things that rupert is talking about
i kind of suspect that those would have
to have quite a bit different properties
but just to be clear our fields are
uh and in fact in fact the things that
we deal with are strictly speaking not
even fields right so so we work with
spatial distributions of resting
potentials so it's not clear to me that
these are really fields in the
mathematical sense of of the word field
but these are distributions of
electrical potentials of living cells in
in a particular body so they are
they're they're very physical they're
local they're you know kind of quite
quite traditional distributions of
voltage
another application that i've heard you
mentioned though it was i don't know if
it was more on the speculative side or
if you've developed this
it was some organism of the potential of
creating some organism that
spontaneously and temperamentally goes
out and cleans up the environment it's
engineered to remove certain toxins
can you speak more about that
yeah that's probably was referring to
our zenobots so we have this uh
this technology where we're we're
creating synthetic living
proto-organisms made in this in this
case made of frog skin so these are frog
skin cells that in different
environments self-organized to be these
these little motile creatures
and at least one of many possible
applications in the future is to program
them for some sort of collection
tasks so that they would go out and
maybe collect
useful useful molecules or maybe they
would clean up toxins maybe they would
detect various various other chemicals
in the environment that you would want
to know about so these are all potential
uh applications of of the practical sort
of use of these kinds of synthetic
living machines
you mentioned quite a few times that
it's important when you're dealing with
the manipulation of this electric
field or voltage gradient that you don't
use external electric fields you
actually manipulate the cellular ion
channels directly yeah okay so then i
was wondering does this mean you know
how some people say 5g
that we should be scared of 5g because
well for various reasons
but then other people say it's
non-ionizings and that's and that's all
that matters well is that all that
matters is there some validity to being
concerned about 5g
um so so i think i think both of those
viewpoints are a little bit off and the
truth is somewhere in the middle so so
let's let's just start with the ionizing
business so so i i think the evidence is
quite clear that electromagnetic
radiation does not need to be ionizing
and in fact it is not to be particularly
strong in order to in some way affect
living cells so living things so living
things are sensitive to all sorts of
electromagnetic radiation uh in many
ways that do not require ionization or
heat or anything like that at the same
time
i think i don't have any reason to be
concerned about 5g first of all the
kinds of things that we study so these
bioelectric signaling
pathways are not particularly affected
by external electromagnetic fields if
they were we would be using these kinds
of things in the lab to manipulate the
electrical
the electrical signaling it's just not
it's not a great way to control
bioelectric
signaling within tissue it's it just
doesn't do a very good job of it so i
don't have any particular reason to be
worried about 5g i have a feeling that
uh for most people that are worried
about it you have far bigger dangers and
stressors in your life you know uh if
you eat certain things if you uh engage
in certain behaviors
this is far more of an issue for you
statistically than than 5g ever will be
so so i'm i i'm not particularly worried
about 5g on a on a practical level in
the in the grand scheme of things that i
worry about in the things that we all do
in our life that are sort of not optimal
for health i think 5g is probably way
down on the list of things for you to
worry about however i think it's it's
not true to say that uh because it's
non-ionizing we don't need to worry
about it i think that's actually false
okay speaking about diet you mentioned
eating and then in one of your talks you
also mentioned there's a connection
between the microbiome and this
morphogenetic field but i didn't hear
more elaboration on that so if you don't
mind elaborating they'll be great
yeah well
the general point is that
any sort of
uh kind any any sort of
modality that that controls the behavior
of cells in an organism automatically
becomes the target of an evolutionary
arms race of other organisms that live
near you on you within you and so on
because they can potentially manipulate
those controls to make specific things
happen in the body right so so anything
including chemical signaling
neurotransmitters we already know that
the microbiome is affecting mood and
behavior and things like that by
plugging into the neurotransmitter
pathways so there's this gut brain axis
and so on
so the same is true of bioelectric so so
in general you we could certainly assume
that various microbes that live in the
body and various other kinds of
parasites would have ways of tweaking
ion channel activities meaning probably
using some sort of you know chemicals
that they would be putting out to
manipulate your tissues way in ways that
would be
evolutionarily advantageous to them now
it just so happens we have a practical
example of this that we studied a couple
years ago in planaria
where and this was done in collaboration
with
ben wolf's lab at tufts where we showed
that there are bacteria that live on
these planaria and these bacteria are
actually able to manipulate the worms to
for example alter the structure of their
visual system to have multiple heads and
so on and that is because these uh these
bacteria are able to
tweak the same kinds of controls that
the worm tissues are using in the first
place to make decisions about how many
heads you're supposed to have what what
your visual system should look like so
it's it's it's on the one hand uh kind
of amazing that that these microbes have
a say in the structure of this uh
kind of organism that they live in on
the other hand from an evolutionary
point of view is completely expected
that they would have discovered ways to
do that
earlier in our talk you mentioned that
when you were looking for these voltage
gradients when you did this die the
voltage die you saw something that it
was a conspicuous face on the frog and
then you also mentioned well
you don't imagine that the code will be
that obvious for the majority of what we
care about especially for humans how is
it that you go about finding out or
decoding this code
and also what other factors matter is it
the do they pulse the voltage pulses and
then so the frequency of pulsing matters
doesn't move like what are the factors
that go in to
determining the code and then how do you
decode it
yeah um we don't know many of the things
about it so for example at the moment it
doesn't look like there's pulsing and
that the the temporal aspects of it are
particularly critical but that's
probably more a function of the fact
that we haven't really dug into it yet
but it's entirely possible that when we
we dig into the temporal aspects we will
find out that the time dependent changes
are really important it's possible at
the moment we've been completely
occupied with the spatial aspects and it
doesn't look at least to our technology
it doesn't look like it's uh
pulsing in in that particular way but we
may have simply not found it yet
uh in terms of in terms of how do you
how do you crack the code so
um there's a few there's a few pieces to
this one piece is simply observation
right so it's almost everything in
science starts with some sort of
observation and really just getting a
database or a profile of different
tissues under different conditions a
bioelectric profile of different tissues
under different different conditions
will be absolutely crucial to decoding
this because we need the same way that
we currently have databases of gene
expression of proteomics of um
all all these kind of biochemical and
and genetic profilings of tissues and
health and disease and different cells
of the body and so on uh we need the
exact same thing for bioelectric so we
need a kind of physiomic profiling where
there ought to be a database where we
can go and say this particular tissue
under these conditions should be in this
we have this bioelectric pattern and
here are the sort of range of normal and
here's how a difference between between
people and between the organisms in
different states and so on so that
that's that's the first thing and so we
only have that for very small number of
cases
we certainly don't have anything like a
full physiomic profiling yet
then what you need to do is you need to
build computational models that help you
explain why the electrical pattern is
the way it is given the various channels
and pumps that are
that are expressed in that tissue and
then you begin the hard work of
functional experiments so you open and
close some channels you observe what
happens and you build up uh a theory
based on an improved computational model
of how that
particular bioelectric pattern triggers
the downstream effects that it has so
for example we know now there's a
pattern that corresponds to make an eye
there's another pattern that corresponds
to build whatever goes at this location
of a wound we have a pattern that says
build a nice sharp brain the edge of a
brain and so we have a pattern that says
um don't be a tumor be normal tissue and
so on these kinds of um
these kinds of patterns need to be uh
need to be identified and that can only
be done
with uh this kind of mapping of of
pattern to the particular outcome and
then there's a lot of computational work
that goes in between
do you think psychedelics have any role
to play in
in changing or altering the
morphogenetic morphological code what i
mean is
you know after a single initial dose
there's markedly increased openness and
i'm wondering well is that because
there's a change in some non-neural
bioelectric activity
i have no idea uh i i've been no
expertise in in psychedelics whatsoever
i can tell you that much like in the
brain um
there is there's a really uh nice
connection between neurotransmitter
activity in the rest of the body and the
electrical signals that move these
neurotransmitters around so i would not
be at all shocked if there was some
connection and in fact we've certainly
used various compounds that are normally
uh utilized to target uh to target the
brains and so so things like anxiety
lytics and ssris and
various kinds of drugs that are normally
used in the nervous system we've used
them in in embryogenesis
uh in regeneration to to try to tweak
some of these pathways outside the
nervous system so that that's that's for
sure a thing you can do
whether or not it has anything to do
with the mental states induced by these
kind of compounds in humans i have no
idea
i know these questions are desolatory
they keep
going from subject to subject it's just
how my notes were but well regardless
you mentioned one time i think it was to
sean carroll that you can use daniel
dennett's way of speaking of intention
that is
i believe it was give as much intention
as you like to a system in order to
explain what's happening and when i say
intention i mean act as if it's willing
to do something
and then you also mention that when one
scales down one's theological projection
to smaller particles like pan psychics
might do then it leads naturally to
quantum indeterminacy and the least
action principle okay so let's start
from the beginning uh the
dan dennett's intentional stance
is the basically the following idea that
the real answer
to whether due to how much
intentionality but you know he usually
talks about consciousness but but
intentionality cognition intelligence
whatever whatever you're interested in
the real question of how much of that
some particular system has is not to be
found by sort of armchair philosophy
right to just assume and you know people
say this all time they say things like
well thermostats can't possibly have any
intention or you know
so so this is this is a decision that
somebody had made it has made just by uh
by by fiat basically and and and dan's
point is is very important it's that
it's an empirical question you can't
just you can't just decide and the way
that you discover this is simply this
you take a particular stance and you say
here's my system i think it has this
much intelligence or i think it's
capable of learning or i think it's able
to
uh have preferences in the you know or i
think it's a goal directed system
whatever whatever
wherever you choose to uh to start on
that continuum
and using that stance you do empirical
experiments to see how well that stands
helps you to understand what and control
whatever you're dealing with and so the
point being that we can't simply assume
that something is a non-intelligent
system because of what it's how it's
made or because of how it looks you have
to actually ask
does
what is the optimal way of looking at
that system so just to give you a simple
a simple analogy if you have a ball on
top of a hill you are pretty well um
you're going to do pretty well using the
newton's laws to ask how it's going to
roll down the hill and if you have
additional theories about the hopes and
dreams of this ball as it rolls down the
hill they're not going to do you much
good right they're not going to give you
any improved ability to uh to to
understand and control what's going to
happen on the other hand if you start
off with a with a with a live mouse at
the top of a hill and you think you're
going to apply newton's laws you're not
going to do very well uh because you're
going to need some other laws and so you
might decide that the system is is
minimally intelligent and see how you do
you might decide that the system is very
intelligent and it has memories of of
what happened when you put it on the
hill last week and it might do something
different
the point is it's an empirical
experiment you can't just decide what
it's going to be you have to uh you have
to choose a a level of abstraction of
some type of
learning agent maybe maybe all maybe
very little maybe quite a lot and see
how you do so so that's uh so that's
that's the intentional stance is that
that everything is to be decided by the
quality of the predictions and the
amount of control you gain by viewing
your system in a particular light right
so so so everything is is in a way
observer dependent and it's dependent on
the on the
experimental context in which you want
to examine the system you know a a human
brain is very intelligent in a certain
context it also makes a great
paperweight and if and if that's the the
how you choose to look at it then you're
you don't need uh to understand to
attribute much intelligence to it if
you're examining the problem space of
keeping down some papers in a wind then
then it doesn't come up
so so that's so that's so that's that
and so my uh where where i intersect
with this is that
i basically point out that
uh this is a really essential
uh this is a really essential way of
looking at things when
traditional phylogenetics
is is not a great guide and this is
meaning that when we are confronted with
novel creatures they might be novel
bioengineered creatures they might be
chimeras they might be uh something that
you find in space somewhere some
exobiological agent they might be
artificial intelligences that we create
whatever it is
when you are confronted with something
that you cannot simply place on the
familiar evolutionary tree of life in on
earth and say oh yeah this thing is uh
closely related to a fish therefore i'm
going to
i'm going to assume it has roughly the
cognition of other fish that i've known
so when you are
cr either creating or reverse
engineering
novel creatures the intentional stance
becomes completely essential because you
can't know a priori what the cognitive
capacities of this thing are going to be
and they might be uh it might behoove
you to really attribute quite a lot of
cognition to it or maybe not at all
depending on
how
how that does for you in terms of
empirical success so having said that
then the natural question might come up
is there a zero on this scale so if
you've got a scale uh a a continuum of
cognition or of intelligence that that
is a smooth gradient where different
types of systems might might land right
and so the question is is there in fact
a zero and so what i was saying is is
simply this that
if you
uh if if somebody if somebody had said
to me um
what would the absolute minimum
what would you have to have an absolute
minimum in order to be on this scale at
all right so so to be somewhere on the
scale of cognitive creatures what's the
what's the basement right what's what's
the minimal version that you would have
to have i would say probably the minimum
you would have to have two things you
would have to have some ability to do
goal directed behavior so you would have
to have some kind of ability to to
pursue goal states and you would have
you would have to have some kind of uh
internal uh control such that your
um
your your behavior and the things you do
are not perfectly described by all the
external influences around you at a
given time
right in other words in other words if
if i can if i can look at all of the
forces impinging on you and know exactly
what's going to happen then you're
probably a marble running down you know
some kind of an incline plane otherwise
otherwise if if you're if you're more
complex than that
then i would have to take into account
things that happened before things that
might happen in the future all kinds of
things that are not immediately what's
what's what's there so so what that
boils down to is some sort of internally
uh internally uh initiated action some
some some quote-unquote freedom and
that's you know that's a whole other
story to really dig into that but this
idea that that you would be able to
initiate things on your own you're not
just a responding you're not you're not
just a passive responder to forces
around you at that time and so having
said that having said those two things
you realize that already uh particles
already have those two things because
because particles already exhibit
quantum indeterminacy where they do
things that are that are fundamentally
not caused by any of the things around
them right they're complete it's
completely uh sort of um
indeterminate and they have the ability
to pursue goals in a very
uh sort of a very primitive manner which
is which are these least action
principles and so
one of the benefits of people often say
that um that that pan psychism
is it's it's a bad theory because
because it doesn't lead anywhere it
doesn't give you anything and i think
it's certainly there's there's there's a
little bit of truth to that but
there's um
there's also the fact that if you were
to ask the question
uh
i think that even par if you were to say
that i think even particles should have
some degree of gold directed activity
you might make a prediction
of of something like least action
principles existing and then you would
be right you would find you know they
that that model actually makes a
prediction that's completely not obvious
it is it isn't obvious that uh that that
when you have a um
a beam of light passing through a bunch
of lenses it's it's not obvious that you
can actually
forego the calculations of how the light
will interact at the at with the glass
at every point along the way and simply
say you know what i think i think it
wants to get where it's going with the
least amount of uh action right and so
and so you can you can make the correct
prediction of where it's going to go
simply by assuming that the light likes
to get where it's going
by minimizing and maximizing certain
things and you could predict something
like that if you had this idea that even
at the very bottom there would be some
type of
uh some type of
goal directed activity so if we ask what
does that look like what does agency and
intelligence look like in the very
minimal the the most minimal version
possible i think what you get is
something like like particles so from
that perspective i suspect there is no
zero on this scale because because even
particles are already on the scale
okay this zero was that the way that i
understand that is that that's like an
intelligence scale do you synonymize
that with
consciousness right that's that's a good
question uh i will say that um in my
um
writing on all of this stuff i've almost
completely avoided consciousness okay i
almost never talk about consciousness i
talk about cognition and and that's
that's kind of on purpose um i
don't have my my views on consciousness
are not
uh
fleshed out to the point where i'd be
interested in talking about them because
i don't think i can add anything yet
that a lot of other smart people haven't
already chewed over what i think i have
um
something to contribute is to the to the
questions of of cognition and
intelligence because those things are
empirically measurable they're absorbed
publicly observable behaviors and we can
we can have a research program focused
around them that i think is is different
than what other people have been doing
so that's what i've been talking about
consciousness is different um
in the sense that i think many of the
people who study who who say they study
consciousness in fact do not study
consciousness what they study at best
are correlates of consciousness or
oftentimes behaviors and properties that
may or may not have anything to do with
actual consciousness and so i think it's
very difficult to study actual
consciousness if you you have to
studying consciousness is a first person
activity it's not a third person
activity the way that you would study
anything in the external world meaning
studying it externally outside of
yourself i think fundamentally studying
consciousness requires
the subject of meaning you or whoever is
studying it to actually change during
during that that that process it's a
it's a completely different thing so so
i'm i'm i'm working on some things along
those lines it's a little early uh it's
a little early to talk about it
faraz hanarvar asks could the mapping
and thereby the treatment of the
signaling that is this electric
signaling differ between individuals
when we're talking about humans so does
the code is the code species dependent
or can it actually differ
based upon people
yeah um i don't think it's even species
dependent because we've seen that we can
induce let's say one species of flatworm
to form a head that belongs to a
completely different species simply by
by changing the distribution of gap
junctional connections
uh i suspect there are massive
uh conservations in the same way that
the biochemical and genetic codes are
are highly highly conserved
um are there going to be individual
differences among patients for sure and
we need to understand what those are we
do not yet know what those are that's a
major area for future research but i
think it's going to be conserved
sufficiently that we will be able to
have general purpose
electroceuticals however i think that
there will have to be some very serious
computational modeling that is going to
likely be personalized that is we're
going to have to take into account the
various physiological and
genetic states of the patient in terms
of do they have any ion channel
mutations what what other kinds of
physiological things are going on in
their blood in terms of ion content and
so on in order to perfect some of these
some of these treatments i think it will
be very much personalized but underneath
it all is going to be a highly conserved
bioelectric code
you mentioned electroceuticals which
reminds me of your company
morphoceuticals so if you're allowed to
talk about that what's the state of it
what's the goal of it
yeah the goal of the goal so so
morphaceuticals inc is a it's a new
company that um i co-founded with david
kaplan who's uh head of biomedical
engineering at tufts uh he and i are
partners in this work we work very
closely together
and the right now the mission of
morphoceuticals is focused around limb
regeneration so we are taking the things
we learned in the frog in terms of how
to
induce the regeneration of appendages in
the frog and trying to move it to
mammals so that someday towards humans
and so you know i can't really go into
details of how it's going but it's in
its very early days but i'm i'm very
optimistic that uh we will actually have
something something useful
so that's what we're doing are you
seeing more progress than you would
hoped or are you seeing less or
is it going pretty much how you expect
it basically going the way i thought it
would it's in the we're on track we're
on track given the the timeline that
we've envisioned and the basic science
that has to be done i mean this is let's
to be clear and and i receive all kinds
of um emails and phone calls from people
with with with really desperate medical
conditions and it's it's just it's an
amazing the need is incredible and and
unfortunately i have to say to all these
people every day that uh we're working
as fast as we can but it's still a basic
science
project it is we are not in clinical
trials we are not dealing with human
patients it is still very basic science
however it is now to the point where we
have commercial investment and it's
obvious that it's going to at some point
it's going to be real for patients
so um it's pretty much on track uh the
idea is uh this is quite simple uh david
um
david's group makes these wearable
bioreactors
and
uh you wear them on a limb amputation
site and they basically produce a kind
of
uh protective aqueous environment around
the around the wound and then my group
comes up with the payload which are the
drugs these are the electroceuticals
which are different types of ion channel
drugs and other other types of drugs
that are going to set the wound cells
towards a decision of let's let's
rebuild let's rebuild the limb
okay nadia wants to know would be very
interested in learning how the actual
algorithm works if he's even allowed to
share that information i guess it's some
form of pattern recognition but the
details would be cool to learn which
which which yeah i'm not sure which
algorithm was she talking about i think
she means the algorithm of when we
talked about decoding
decoding oh
like frog's face means frog's face
yeah
and then she has a sub question which
may be related also how do we know that
we are actually learning the cells
language and not just observing the
cause and effect because we only see
their behavior on the outside
well um i want i guess to go in order uh
the algorithm is still very much under
development part of the problem is that
traditional
machine learning algorithms require
incredible amounts of data meaning
meaning huge numbers of examples to
learn from we don't we don't have those
data so it's it's very expensive and
time consuming to get these images of
the electric pattern so we can't deploy
the typical types of algorithms that are
used
so we're still we're still a lot of the
early work was basically done by hand
and
we're at the moment uh still is that
we're still working on these algorithms
so that's still very much a uh kind of a
a story in progress uh with respect to
the second question i guess i'm not sure
what the distinction would be so if we
understand the bioelectric signals
sufficiently that we can put out
whatever whatever signal we want and get
the cells to do what we want i think by
definition that means we've communicated
correctly to the cells which means by
definition we've learned their
appropriate language i'm not sure what
it would mean to be able to do that and
yet not really have the language of the
cells
sam thompson wants to know do you think
biological self-organization and
emergence might be proto-algorithmic
and then what with the implications of
for that what would the implications be
for science
i don't know what proto-algorithmic
means in this context
um i can take i can take a stab at uh
i think what might be an interesting
sense of it but i'm not sure that
captures what he was asking
the kind of thing that i think is
important sort of foundationally to
think about
is
where
do the set points of various uh
homeostatic systems come from so so
whether you have physiological
homeostasis or anatomical homeostasis
the ability of a system to get back to
the same
state even though it's it's perturbed
right one might ask where is that
information and an easy thing to say is
that well it's it's evolution provides
it because certain types of um set
points are adaptive and other time other
types will will not you will not let you
survive
and
that's okay except that now what we see
with these synthetic organisms is that
for example with the xenobots we can
take these frog skin cells and put them
in a new environment and within 48 hours
or so they
self-assemble into a new organism with a
new anatomy a new behavior and various
new capabilities
they never existed before they have no
lengthy history of selection on earth
right the the cells themselves evolved
for being really good at sitting on the
outside of a frog or a tadpole and
keeping out the bacteria they did not
evolve for the ability to get together
and run around by themselves and do
various things so that raises the
interesting question of where does that
actually come from right what the the
it's clear that there's incredible
plasticity of the hardware that's
encoded by the genome it can do all
sorts of novel things but where does
where do the specific things come from
and i don't know if this is what he
meant by proto-algorithmic but
you can sort of think about it one of my
favorite analogies is this thing called
a galton board i don't know if everybody
knows what that is but imagine imagine a
vertical piece of wood like this it's a
vertical piece of wood and then you bang
a bunch of nails into it at you know
regularly spaced intervals you just bang
a bunch of nails into it you take them
you take a bucket of marbles and you
dump it into the top and they go boom
boom boom they all go and every marble
just sort of bounces stochastically back
and forth
if if if you've got enough marbles the
outcome is always going to be exactly
the same you're going to get this
beautiful bell curve
right if you just visualize and i
actually have toys of this you can
actually buy one on amazon it's like
twinkle from price is right yeah yeah
yeah very very similar very similar but
you dump a whole you see if you dump one
marble you have no idea where it's gonna
end up but if you dump a bunch of
marbles in then on average you're going
to get this beautiful bell curve and so
you can ask a simple question where is
the shape of this bell curve encoded
was it in the description of the wood no
was it in the layout of the nails no you
could put the nails almost any which way
you want was it in the in the recipe of
making this thing no
um where was it and so
you end up with this idea that
much like and this is certainly i'm not
the first person by far to to to say
this this is a very old you know maybe
maybe pythagoras or plato had similar
ideas where
you would say that somewhere in an
important sense there are laws laws of
mathematics laws of computation that
exist independent of
uh well independent they have an
independent existence and what happens
is that when we build specific kinds of
machines we couple to those laws and we
take advantage of them so for example if
you
build a a machine that looks like a
galton board you get to couple to the
rules of mathematics that give you this
beautiful shape you didn't have to
specify the shape ahead of time you get
the shape for free by building a device
that can couple to those laws if you
discover a transistor which is basically
just a uh voltage-gated current
conductance right it's so it's like a
little tiny synapse you know it's the
same as a gap junction an ion channel as
soon as you've made that little machine
you can couple to these amazing laws of
computation that tell you for example
that if you have a bunch of nand gates
you can build anything well where did
that fact come from you know these truth
tables or if you know two angles of a
triangle you automatically know the
third way where that come from so so
where is that so so maybe that's what he
meant by proto-algorithmic but it's the
idea that
there are these rules and some of the
some of them are physics some of them
are mathematics and some of them are
computation
you can if you make the right kind of
device you can reap the benefits of of
some of those laws and evolution does
this all the time evolution discovers
certain pieces of hardware that then let
you do amazing amazing things because
you're leveraging these laws that are
out there that are invisible to you
until you've built the right hardware
great we'll just get to four more
questions hopefully they're quick
feign is the evolutionary suppression of
regeneration in mammals an advantageous
trait for the accumulation of memory
wow uh i'm not sure about for the
accumulation of memory i i doubt it
because there are plenty of creatures
that uh it can do perfectly well with
memory that that are highly regenerative
so so i don't think that it's um you
need to you i don't think it's
impossible to have a regenerative
capacity and memory in the same animal
however um we can think about
why
don't you why aren't humans for example
regenerating their limbs so so nobody
knows but but i'll tell you a plausible
story that may or may not be correct
imagine that you are the ancestor of
mammals you're the tiny
thing that looks a little bit like a
mouse and you're running around the
forest and somebody bites your leg off
so the problem is that unlike a
salamander which can hang out in water
and take a long time to heal you have a
rapid metabolism you have a rapid
heartbeat and blood pressure and
you're going to bleed out long before
you get a chance to regenerate so your
job if you want to survive is to form a
scar and to have an inflammatory
response that's going to kill off with
some of the bacteria you need to not
bleed out so you need to seal the wound
immediately you need to make a scar and
by the way you are going to try to put
weight on it because you're walking on
it unlike unlike a salamander which has
the buoyancy of water to hold you up
you're going to try to put weight on it
which means that as soon as some kind of
delicate blastema is formed and these
cells are starting to grow you're going
to grind it into the forest floor so
that's not particularly conducive also
because you're you're in dry air instead
of water all of the electrical currents
that need to come out of that wound
epithelium to drive the electric states
they can't work because the dry air is a
is an insulator
so uh you might imagine that at that
point you might as well just shift the
scarring because the regeneration now
that story
has pros and cons um
one nice thing about that story is that
for example it fits with this really
weird fact why are
why are deer regenerative on their
antlers why can deer regenerate massive
amounts of bone and vasculature and
innervation every year
i mean what's interesting about the deer
is they're not putting weight on it
they're catering and carrying it around
and they never have to it never has to
worry that it's going to be disrupted
while it's trying to grow so so that's
that's one part you know that that that
fits what doesn't fit is questions like
well okay that explains why the limbs
don't regenerate how about internal
organs why don't they regenerate right
and we don't know so the you know so no
one knows and we can come up with some
ideas that
have sort of pros and cons
tom carrick asks well it says
fascinating are there overlaps with the
field of quantum biology what about orc
or that is i'm sure you've heard of
stewart hammeroffs and penrose's
orchestrated objective reduction
yeah
um
i don't know
i i can't say too many useful things
about that but but i will say sort of
one thing uh
i
do agree with uh with with uh hameroff
and penrose on the idea that anesthesia
in general is
one of the most profound
maybe maybe the only profound tool we
have to study actual consciousness right
that's we we don't have a lot of other
tools to study consciousness but
anesthesia is a pretty good one and the
interesting thing about anesthesia is
that
in general most general anesthetics are
gap junctional disruptors
now this this this has uh like many uh
facts as things that are that are easy
to understand and some things that are
deeply puzzling the e the kind of uh
thing that makes perfect sense is that
these these electrical networks in the
body
manifested various cognitive abilities
long before they were brains so these
gap junctions that enable body cells to
form networks are critical for these
networks to have memories memories of
body shape but to make decisions about
what they're going to grow and so on so
so the use of gap junctions to
make networks that can follow
large scale goals like make a limb and
make an organ and so on that's
evolutionarily ancient and it's not
surprising at all that what evolution
did when the nervous systems develop was
to use that same trick to create another
type of cognitive agent which which
lives basically central ascension
centered in the brain and use this the
exact same reuse the exact same hardware
for that so that makes sense and so it
makes total sense that that goes away
when when uh those gap generators are
disrupted by a general anesthetic it
also makes total sense that if we want
to turn a planarian it into the head of
make its head turn its head into uh the
head of a different species of planarian
guess what we use a general anesthetic
called octanol it's the exact same thing
it's a gap junctional disruptor so what
you're doing is you're basically
disrupting that proto-cognitive agent
the collective intelligence of the body
that normally remembers how to make a
particular kind of head you're basically
disrupting that with this general
anesthetic now the amazing thing about
general anesthetic is that any of us
ever come back from it being the same
person think about it you have this
brain
you have you have right it's a it it
supports the cognitive structures of a
very complex creature and then
for some number of hours you simply
disconnect most of the cells from being
electrically
in communication with each other and
then you let the connections reform
and you just sort of hope that
everything comes back to how it was
right if i didn't know
you know if we didn't know that the
general anesthetics work somebody were
to tell me that that's their plan i
would say
well you might get a living living human
out of it at the end but certainly not
going to be the patient that walked in
you you know you're going to bear no
resurrection yeah of course you're going
to completely wreck their mental state
and and so so one thing that's amazing
is that actually most people come out of
it being the more or less the same
person as they went in
but the other interesting thing is not
everybody so in fact um there is this is
why they don't give they don't like to
give general anaesthetic if they can
help it because some people have
permanent psychosis some people um in
fact many people have hallucinations on
their way out um out of it that
eventually resolve as the brain sort of
finds its its attractors that were there
before but if you watch you can go to
youtube and you can watch some really um
sort of funny videos of people coming
out of general anesthesia right and you
know people think they're pirates and
they're gangsters and they you know they
don't understand where where they've
been and they have all these crazy
stories about who they think they are
and eventually that sort of resolves and
not really that part's not really
surprising i'm shocked anybody ever
comes out of it you know properly that
it's amazing
so uh the planaria is exactly the same
thing so when you disrupt their um their
gap junctions
the first thing they do is they
regenerate random heads that belong
possibly to other species right and then
after about uh 30 days
those heads actually remodel back to the
correct species a species-specific shape
so
they're not permanent so so to me this
looks exactly like what happens when you
come out of general anesthesia
okay mo flow wants to know how does he
see his work relating to david
sinclair's biological clock
yeah um yeah interesting uh it's it's
funny i've been talking a lot i talked
to david recently and i uh i've been
thinking a lot about um people have been
asking me a lot about aging bioelectrics
of aging
um i i don't know i don't know what the
relationship between bioelectrics and
aging really is
um
i can tell you that
uh planaria as far as we can tell don't
age there's no such thing as an old
planarian they live forever if
you know if they're not injured and so
uh
i think what that tells us is that aging
it would be resolved if we could crank
up regenerative capacity to the point
where we would constantly be
regenerating any to any cells that that
aged right senescing cells would just be
regenerated the way planaria do
so my sis my strong suspicion is that
uh aging is a is a
a consequence of our poor ability to
stay
with the appropriate anatomical
structure through long periods of time
and if we cracked that problem we would
simultaneously get the answer to to
aging cancer degenerative disease and
traumatic injury i think it all comes
down to the ability to to to defend a
particular body plan over time
i know many people say that telomere
length has to do with aging well the
shortened telomere length and you're
suggesting well it could be that but
it's also related to this
morphogenetic code that you're referring
to and
yeah are they interrelated somehow
probably i mean i am not an expert on
telomeres i have no idea what's going on
with telomeres in planaria i'm assuming
somebody's studying it we certainly
haven't i'm assuming somebody must be
all i know is
this this story of
inevitable aging because you keep making
copies of things and fundamentally
things are the information is degrading
and eventually you you don't have it
anymore uh and it's degrading at the
ends because you know because that's
where you're eating that that clearly
cannot be the whole story because
planaria avoided permanently so whatever
they're doing
is uh is is is the way to get around
aging and i think it's more than a
coincidence that the species that is
immortal is also the species with the
greatest regenerative capacity or let's
say the set of species so i i don't
think that's a that's a that's a crazy
coincidence that i think there's there's
a reason for that
okay the last question
nate brundman can you imagine
referring to you michael can you imagine
a mental practice by which a person can
influence the goal state of the body for
example joe dispenza has made some
claims that he's healed his body in a
way that doctors say are impossible it
also a question i had for you earlier
which relates to this is
how your work is related to the placebo
effect
so
whether or not you see the connection
there i'm interested in the placebo
effect too i'm trying to sneak in two
questions for the pressure one
yeah um okay so so i i don't know
anything about uh joe dispenza i don't
know anything about the claims that he's
made or or any specific uh you know kind
of uh healing event
but i'll give you kind of a general
thought about this
it is
uncontroversial
that
your your thoughts whatever they may be
whether or not uh you know whatever
whatever you think thinking is it is
pretty uncontroversial that your
thoughts affect the physiological
functioning of your body i mean that's
obvious if you if you want to get up and
walk around your thoughts have now
activated various uh electrical pathways
they've triggered a bunch of muscle
motion if you have a tendency to you
know mentally work yourself up into an
anxious state you can certainly by by by
your thinking uh crank up various stress
enzyme production in your body right we
all know that you can do the opposite if
you if you've trained in techniques to
calm yourself down under various
circumstances you can uh reduce the
level of cortisol in your blood you can
reduce um various uh various fire and
flight responses so it's it's it's not
some some some weird um you know of a
voodoo kind of claim to uh to say that
that your thoughts absolutely affect the
biophysical processes of your body we do
it every day if that wasn't true you
couldn't get up in the morning when you
wanted to get up and go to work so so
it's it's that part's completely obvious
so from there it's a very
short uh hop skip and a jump to the idea
that
not only can you give commands to your
muscles and your glands to produce
various
hormones neurotransmitters and muscle
motion but you might be able to exert
some influence over other cells for
example skin cells um in your uh you
know at wounds and and uh and you and
your liver the in the way that it
processes information
i don't find it implausible whatsoever
so i don't again i'm not commenting on
any particular instance of anybody
having healed themselves of anything i'm
just saying that
it is it is uh it is it is not
uh it is not a stretch to think that not
only can you talk to your van
when i say talk i mean you know exert
exert influence
on your uh on your various glands that
that put out cortisol and adrenaline and
various other things
why can't why can't you send commands to
other cells i that that seems it seems
silly to think that that's impossible
so um
having said all that i think that uh the
placebo effect is extremely profound i
think that what it's telling us is that
there is a communication across levels
so you have meaning that you have a
level of organization that consists of
your body cells and that has a degree of
cognition and a degree of intelligence
but your body is also home to an
additional intelligence which lives
probably largely in the brain and it
appears that those two can uh can
communicate in various ways and i can
imagine that
there are new there are lots of things
to be discovered about ways to improve
that communication and have you know we
know we know there are certain practices
where people extend the amount of time
they can they can sit under water and
and uh change their body temperature and
and change their their pulse rate and
things like that i find it completely
plausible that that there are ways to uh
communicate in that way to other cells
in the body
also
uh
there is the there is the field of um
hypno dermatology where where people by
hypnosis try to treat various skin
diseases some of which have a neural
neuroimmune component some of which may
not have a neuroimmune component
so um the activity of of the mind which
is simply the execution of of the
physiological computations that happen
in the brain affect physiological
computations that happen outside the
brain i don't think that's i don't think
that's particularly a stretch
at all
one of your goals is an anatomical
compiler and then what you just said
made me think well some of these people
who are meditating or on the more
meditative side tend to work with
thoughts to heal oneself then i was
wondering hmm i wonder if your
anatomical compiler can advise some of
the more thought-based healing practices
here's an example you say well if you
were to think of this image it's more
likely to heal you than if you were to
think of this other image do you think
that's at all possible or that's way too
high level
i don't think it's i don't think it's
impossible no uh
again i'm not suggesting that there's
i'm not supporting any particular image
of as being a healing one but i don't
think it's it's impossible at all i mean
the
uh and and there's been work recently on
various types of um pulsed light stimuli
into the retina having some some
interesting neuro
neuroprotective effects in the brain and
so on um yeah all of this it's it's a
giant electrical network all of the
cells are communicating with each other
uh there's absolutely no reason why that
couldn't work but i think that um you
know to be clear this anatomical
compiler isn't just us you know
the anatomical compiler is a
it's a sort of practical um
personification of the goal that all of
us in the community are going for which
is the ability to control growth and
form right and and when we have that
ability that's when the anatomical
compiler becomes positive possible so
it's not just something that we you know
we in particular are working on
but i think that uh this is this is part
of all the things you're discussing now
are part of the deep reason why
cognitive science and consciousness and
all of those kinds of things are deeply
related to developmental biology and
physiology right they're they're
absolutely interrelated because they are
two sides of the same coin information
processing in goal-directed hierarchical
systems and when you understand the more
you understand about one the better you
are at managing the others this is this
is two sides of the same question
where can people find out more about you
and what's next for you
well uh they can find out uh i have a i
have a website um
at
drmik11.org uh we have a center website
which is allencenter.tufts.com
i have a twitter feed which is at
drmik11
and uh what's next uh it's a good
question i i don't you know i can't tell
you exactly what's going to happen next
but i certainly know the things that we
are trying to do and that we're working
on
and you can go to our website and see
all kinds of projects that we're working
on
in the um
in the areas of trying to lay a better
foundation for understanding basal
cognition and
understanding morphogenesis and
developing applications and birth birth
defects and regeneration and cancer
we're doing some work in machine
learning and trying to sort of close
that loop and understand how
we can use the principles that we learn
in biology to make better uh cognitive
to to make novel and better um cognitive
systems that are going to help us in in
various ways
and the links to everything that michael
just mentioned will be in the
description so please check that out you
mentioned two sides of the same coin but
i didn't quite understand that how is it
that developmental biology and
consciousness may be two sides because
you mentioned one is first and third
person is the other so how are they two
sides of the same coin
well in in in many ways uh first of all
uh
uh the fact that we all start life as a
single cell and that cell self-assembles
into a creature that can later say i am
a centralized intelligence i am i i
a self yeah that may be but you're made
of a bunch of cells and in fact you used
to be one cell and then a ball of cells
and so that whole process of of how that
that that's that unified self is
arranged uh and and uh supported by a
collection of of competent agents these
being cells is very similar to uh how
the body is in the pattern of the body
is is arranged by the collective
intelligence of cells morphogenesis is a
collective intelligence problem it is
not a chemistry problem or a genetics
problem it's a problem of collective
intelligence and
those same kinds of issues arise when
you're trying to understand any kind of
a
human or any other centralized
intelligence
how does the information processing and
the capacities of lots of independent
subunits in the case of brains those
will be neurons but in the case of the
body there'll be other types of cells
how do they work together to pursue
goals and plans and have preferences
that don't belong to any of the
individual subunits themselves
right the making a limb is a goal that
no individual cell can can no no no
individual cell knows what a limb is or
you can can answer the question for how
many fingers are we supposed to have or
how long is the finger supposed to be
that is a piece of information that only
the cellular collective has right so
this ability of
pursuing large-scale goals of having and
having collective information that's
more than the sum of its parts is
exactly the same question of where does
intelligence uh and and and you know
sort of uh
cognitive capacity come from those are
all
those problems will be answered together
they will not be answered if either one
of these things remains mysterious we
won't have an answer to the other
thank you sir thank you so much for
spending so much thank you very much
yeah thank you for your questions i want
to make let everyone know that this i
think is nobel prize winning work so i i
will do my best to promote this and
and get you
get you some more attention man i hope
so thank you thank you very much that's
very kind thank you i appreciate it
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
slash c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you